Hi, I'm Derrick Dennis. I specialize in
repairing and cleaning washing machines,
dryers, any major appliances.
The two main types of washing
machines that I work on
are top-loaders and front-loaders.
I'm going to show you how I clean them.
So, this top-load washer is, I would say,
between 15 and 17 years old.
This machine here hasn't been cleaned,
I would say, ever since it was purchased.
The biggest problem with this,
the abundance of buildup
from excessive use
of detergent, fabric softener,
all the buildup you see,
that's what causes this
big ring around the top.
The water doesn't come up that high.
That's why you see the different levels.
And then the buildup of mold.
The perfect, ideal circumstance for mold
and mildew buildup is
moisture, darkness, and heat.
So common buildup in these machines
due to overuse of
high-efficiency detergent
and fabric softener, which you don't need.
This big buildup, you're
going to get rust,
you're going to get mold, mildew.
2 tablespoons of high-efficiency detergent
and no fabric softener
will make your machine last ages longer
than if you're dumping a cup
or two of fabric softener.
And it doesn't get your
clothes any cleaner.
I highly recommend cutting
out fabric softener
in your laundry regimen.
The reason that I'm so
against fabric softener
is when you use fabric softener,
the reason that it works is
the reason that it's bad.
So it builds up like an oily residue,
because those enzymes have
been trapped inside your shirt,
and so that's what causes it to smell.
So it's not because of
you, but eventually,
the overuse of high-efficiency detergent
and fabric softener will
cause your clothes to smell,
even if they're clean.
So, anytime we maintenance a machine,
we want to make sure
that we're unplugging it
from any power source,
and it's good to cut the water off.
So, generally we start
from top to the bottom.
The main thing is removing the tub
and cleaning the inner and outer baskets.
That's where all of your smell comes from.
With these direct-drive machines,
a lot of times we have,
the legs are rusty,
and we'll either scrape
them down, repaint them,
make sure we knock the cobwebs out,
all that kind of stuff.
Sometimes we'll find a little baby sock.
You never know.
We like to use toothbrushes,
different-style brushes.
You have pointy brushes, flat brushes.
They all have different jobs,
but brushes are very key.
They're vital to everything we do.
So the brushes really help to get in there
and kind of get in the
corners and the crevices
to clean all this mildew and mold out.
Sometimes the pressure washer
doesn't get inside the balance ring,
and we have some bristles in there
and kind of really put
some elbow grease in it.
My favorite cleaner is
Pine-Sol, bleach, Lysol.
Vinegar is more of what I recommend
for people to use through a washing cycle.
White distilled vinegar
has acetic compounds
that help kill some bacterias.
When we pressure wash,
first we start the outside.
We can get a lot better
into the balance ring.
A pressure washer,
the water finds its ways
into all the crevices,
and it does a much better job
at pushing out all this mold and mildew
and detergent buildup and
fabric-softener buildup
all the way out of the holes.
Then we can just rinse
it out of the inside,
and we have pretty much
a brand-new basket.
So, the steam cleaning usually comes
after the pressure washing
just because we want to
get kind of a final clean.
The best thing about the steamer
is the water comes out at
a superhigh temperature,
and that helps to effectively sanitize
any of these crevices or cracks
or anything that we can't just clean
with a pressure washer or bleach.
So, the front-loader,
the cleaning process,
it's similar, but it's a lot
different in the disassembly
and just the orientation of the basket.
I can't remove a basket all
the way from a front-loader.
I can only clean the front half.
The old-school top-loaders
are built like tanks.
The front-loaders are not,
but they clean your clothes better.
They generally don't need as much cleaning
as a top-loader because of the orientation
and the way the water spins inside,
and the water actually
keeps the tubs cleaner.
The biggest part of the smell that we see
is from pump building up
lint and debris in there
and people not cleaning it out.
And then you stay with a smell,
or because people don't
wipe out their door seal
every time they use the machine,
they keep the door closed,
and then that just
builds up a mildew smell.
As long as you keep the door open
and wipe the door seal out
and run a washer-cleaner tablet through
once a month or so,
white distilled vinegar,
it's not going to smell.
I can guarantee it.
So, with this front loader,
it actually has a clean-out
spot for the lint.
This is what protects your pump,
and this is what helps keep
the smell down internally.
Pull the door down.
We drain the water out of this little,
this is the drain hose that actually pulls
whatever water is left inside the pump.
And then we take the
filter out, clean it out,
and that's it. It's that simple.
I recommend doing this every 30 days,
at least every six months,
and this is going to prevent odor.
It's going to keep your washing machine
lasting a whole lot longer.
The average life span of
pretty much any washer
is two or three years
before the bearings go out,
you know, just because of,
and that really comes from
the overuse of detergent.
So when a detergent breaks
down that oil and grease,
it'll cause the bearings
to get rusted, rusty,
and then your washing machine will sound
like a jet plane taking off.
That's bad bearings.
It's really hard to get to
if you can't physically
tear these things down
and clean them yourself.
So the best thing to do
is preventive maintenance.
2 tablespoons of detergent,
no fabric softener at all,
but if you have to use it,
make sure you dilute it by 50%.
You know, when I sell
a machine to somebody,
I want them to have faith
that I have sold them the
cleanest used washing machine
that they can possibly buy.